do you think you will IPO miss Mr Beast
burger or feastables in the next five
ten years Beast burger or feasible snow
I I kind of think they're something
actually you know what I just realized
that this is our first time talking
about those we're like an hour and a
half in that's so funny we started
talking about what uh uh my retention
brain kicked in
um I wonder if you have retention brain
for like life itself I do every time I'm
talking to someone I can I'm like okay I
wonder about like loved ones like
spending time with loved ones thinking
like we could be doing something much
better right now yes no that is a
serious problem uh with well so we'll
pause the b square question yes but
that's why uh my current girlfriend uh
which I was telling you before when we
were talking about this is she has a
genuine love for Learning and that's
something I have like I always feel like
I need to be learning something to
justify the time I'm spending and so
that's why it's such a nice trait
because I feel like that time is being
used optimally because whether we're
watching a documentary or we're going in
in you know taking an IQ test or reading
about whatever just why Modern Art is
the thing I don't know whatever weird
thing we decided to do I'm always
learning and improving so it justifies
the time so to maximize retention in
your relationship
yeah you want to spend time with that
time learning as much as possible yeah
which conveniently I don't have to force
right or or I want to be recharging so I
when I do work I can you know hit the
ground harder and luckily we're into a
lot of the same things which you know
happen to be learning sometimes it's not
learning like maybe watching an anime or
something like that
um but I'm a big believer and you're
either if you well
if you if your goal is to be like a
super successful entrepreneur you need
to either be working or you need to be
doing something that decompresses and
recharges you so you can work again if
your goal is to be like a really
Kick-Ass entrepreneur obviously we're
boiling this down to like a very basic
thing and so the the things you're doing
your down time when you're not working
if it doesn't recharge you you're
screwed you're just a ticking Time Bomb
waiting to implode
um and so you gotta like heavily
recharge and like so like watching for
me anime or whatever it is playing a
board game like that is actually kind of
crucial to my success which takes a lot
of maturing to come to that conclusion
because I used to be the kind of guy
that wanted to work every hour of the
day and I would try to train myself to
not need that stuff and I you know and I
almost resented like that I I have to do
these kinds of things and it would piss
me off because it's not optimal and you
know I just really want to make content
and entertain people but
yeah as someone who's gone down that
road and you know you just work every
day for two three months straight and
you know every hour of the day and then
you just a bomb waiting to explode and
lose your mind and the only real
sustainable thing is to just like give
yourself time to recharge in between
working
so there's a kind of balance you have to
find you have to even and I hate it more
than anyone else because I you know you
hate not working yes because it's just
not optimal for time like it's it's it's
as a human I do need to occasionally
watch a Mindless show and play a board
game yeah and it took me a very long
time to like come to peace with that and
not I would have like borderline panic
attacks when I do it because I just what
am I doing right now why am I doing this
I should be you know like what if one
day I have to lay off an employee
because we're not doing so well like how
could I justify watching this this show
or whatever I'm doing right now you know
it's like there's a lot of things like
that that go on in your head but it's
necessary